in light of all that's happening right
now it is important to feel prepared
and feel safe luckily our newest sponsor
has you covered these are the end times
and you want to be prepared
but every time you reach for a survival
tool it turns out to be one of your many
sex
toys sex toy sex toy this isn't a boot
it's a sex toy
but what is the opposite of that
introducing the tactical schlong omni
tool from survivor tech
the tactical schlong is the only
multi-purpose survival tool specifically
designed to look
like a freshly used sex toy use the
tactical schlong as a flashlight
to break glass to put out a fire
to start a fire chop wood and thanks to
survivor tech's patented always
glistening technology
the tactical shlon looks like a freshly
used sex toy so no one will try to steal
it
get out of here burglar
use the tactical schlong omni tool for
nunchucks
to land a plane fetch pretend penis
unicorn walrus that workout thing
drug dancing hit a garbage can
and on behalf of everyone at survivo
tech
i just want to say that we're with you
america
we believe in you and we'll get through
this
together the great failure of society is
upon us
be prepared with the tactical swan
good boy